I think that their refusal to exploit
sentient creatures for non necessary
purposes is not just morally virtuous
but a moral obligation should be a
baseline of our ethical conduct not an
extension of it so don't eat me don't
exploit animals don't exploit animals
you know don't eat them don't eat their
products don't wear them don't use them
for entertainment in sport entertainment
I was trying to think of the last time I
used an animal for entertainment that
was Russia before the Internet Alex
looks horrified Oh believe me the things
that happened in factory farms are far
more horrifying yeah of course that's
actually the interesting that's one of
the first interesting points that people
the people will raise their eyebrows at
they don't man this is something that I
realized myself back when I used to eat
meat
someone once made this point to me they
said it's a bestiality it's it's pretty
pretty disgusting and wrong right now so
well I mean instinctively I want to say
yes and they say but but if you have sex
with an animal there's at least a chance
that they might enjoy it having a good
time or at least it's a pleasurable
experience to a conversation is taking a
turn but anyway I'd love you to do that
as a routine at a local comedy club
that'd be [ __ ] brilliant but but like
I this is the thing the eyebrows goes
back a head and then you say but but
think about this right like when it
comes to like slaughtering and killing
an animal that's obviously not in their
best interest probably not enjoying that
kind of thing so it's like it was an
argument from kind of saying like if
we're allowed to literally take a take a
cow put a bolt through its brain turn it
upside down slit its throat and watch it
bleed out but then that's that's just
fine and no one cares but as soon as you
put your penis in it although that's a
big ruckus like I was like that's that's
a really good point now luckily I'm able
to go the one way of saying neither of
those things should be done but I think
as a meat eater these are these are the
kind of these are the kind of services
that you have to start considering like
what else can that kind of justification
allow you to do the kind of
justifications that we produce that we
desperately kind of clamor for we're
trying to continue eating our burgers
and our milk and our eggs those
justification is you want to be careful
with them because they can lead you to a
whole host of really
unfruitful places so how many meet three
days a week direct and you can have if
you want to have sex for the cow once a
week Donna calculus yes wake it up
[Music]